Vegas is back in the house and this time
with an exact pot you'll see very early
that I was not there because of my last
name it is kind of a legacy heavy season
there's a lot of solute names we
recognized so how many Davenport's are
there do we know oh yes
drag race is back with the most
connected cast in the show's history as
you can see from this family ish tree
my grandmother Alyssa how does that work
dr. loyalty I am a curious Chanel
Davenport all the way from that fabulous
house of Davenport where we loved to
drag and this season it will show the
fans I'm going to say you know they want
to relive the whole Coco and Alyssa
moment a lot of people are already just
kind of compare me to Coco okay she's
Coco Montrese his daughter she got a
reputation to live up to let's see she
lived up to that that's understandable
I'm completely different I performed in
Vegas but the reason why I'm on the show
is not because I'm my Vegas Queen
because I have talent to back it up and
I think you guys will see that this
honey raw and unfiltered I'm honey
Davenport and I'm New York City's crown
jewel walking into the show with a known
last name does that put a target on your
back
I didn't feel that way because I knew at
the end of the day I wanted this for my
whole drag career
when it comes to legend Carl in New York
I've been known as for 10 years I'm just
as much of a legend so like I was you
know not only looking to represent my
family but also looking to really like
expose my brand and show my art I was
like this is for me to play my name is
Raja do Hera the D it's short for
Davenport coming into the season right
after Asia O'Hara was on top for it puts
a lot of pressure for sure but you know
I can't give in to that temptation I
can't give in to that pressure I gotta
just do my thing I can't be anybody else
that's come before me
they expect you to dance like Kennedy
dance like Sahara have dragged like him
they have dragged like Sahara you have
to actually break out and become who you
are which is I mercurial I'm not Kennedy
I'm not far I look up to them our drag
aesthetic is very different but it's
definitely like we're watching to see
what the hell she's gonna do because we
know what they did coming to the show
also you get to see how a family-like
evolves you can see definitely
resemblances but also the differences
honey style is anything the hell I feel
like that day I am worried about our
family like they're not it's not their
name they're not honey Davenport I am
honey Davenport I love a good
competition girl the legacy that I come
from has created me and made me into the
Entertainer that I am so that you know
mama could push the little bird out than
this and I can be flat my queen welcome
to RuPaul's Drag Race honey
we're new girls a new generation genre
of drag deal with it learn us love us
let's go
[Music]